>> A BIG HAWK FLYING OVER A BABY
SQUIRREL, GOLF COURSES, AND THAT
BIG HAWK COMES DOWN AND GRABS
THE SQUIRREL, DO YOU SHOOT THE
HAWK OFF OR LET HIM EAT THE
SQUIRREL?
DO YOU KILL THE SQUIRREL OR KILL
THE HAWK?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: I THINK I AM SITTING
THERE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
ANALOGY IS WHAT I'M DOING.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HERE'S THE ANALOGY OF IT --
THE WATER COMPANY, THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN FAMILIES TO FEED AND
NEED THE WATER.
>> Larry: RIGHT.
ARE YOU GOING TO KILL THE
WATER COMPANY --
>> Larry: I'M SORRY, BUT THIS
DOES NOT SOUND LIKE SCARFACE.
I HAVE TO BRING OUT MY ANNOTATED
GUIDE TO SCARFACE BECAUSE THIS
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE -- OKAY, THIS
IS FROM THE GHETTO BOY SONG,
"DAMN IT'S GOOD TO BE A GANGSTA,
FEEDING THE POOR AND HELPING OUT
WITH THEY BILLS."
WHY YOU GOT TO BE SO BRAND-NEW,
BROTHER?
>> I'M NOT BRAND-NEW!
HE'S BRAND-NEW!